that's not the plan
what um what was the first ozone Awards
like
and what year and what year was it 2006.
okay so this is four years after the
magazine launches in Orlando okay yeah I
just remember that honestly there's so
much I don't remember from those
weekends because I did literally did not
sleep like the ozone Awards definitely
in in Orlando and definitely in Houston
I'm talking like four days without sleep
you start to hallucinate things like
when I woke up the morning after I
remember looking up looking around the
room and seeing like wristbands and
stuff and I lit I really thought it had
been a dream I was like that we didn't
actually yeah tomorrow actually happened
yeah
um that was a crazy day I mean I gotta
say that David Banner really saved that
show because he was the host Legend and
I was in like just it was just so much
that happened that weekend because it
wasn't just the awards we did a four day
or maybe it was three days at that time
we teamed up with TJ's DJs which was uh
TJ Chapman
shout out to TJ um and I couldn't have
pulled that off without him I mean he
had a lot more in terms of structure and
he had
staff and volunt I've always been For
Better or Worse like I do everything
myself I'm not really great at
delegating stuff
um two years from Tallahassee too right
he's from Tallahassee yeah and that
first weekend like we had basically we
had paid for this whole hotel and they
told us back then like oh we're going to
be doing some Renovations or whatever
but it'll be done by the time your event
comes around they literally brought a
bulldozer in the lobby of the hotel
three days before the ozone Awards and
it was the whole Lobby was gone like
they had a took out the escalator it was
dirt Jesus and so I get a call from one
of our staff like three days before the
awards um I think you should come see
the hotel where we're having our event
in three days
it was just so much that it was just so
much that um
went wrong that weekend to the point
where by the time the Awards come around
I'm like how are we going to pull this
off you know and I'm like just it was
just so much going on
um back then I had a Blackberry and like
you know the the messages were coming in
so fast I was getting uh like the next
day I got a message from Ludacris
manager like we're at the airport where
is the car like I'm getting messages
from the day before like that's how
crazy it was and who performed the first
year uh literally everybody just
everybody we're being backstage and all
the pictures from that night is funny
because I I'm in like a white T-shirt
because I never even had time to like
change in anything and I hadn't sled so
I'm just like all over the place but um
I was kind of freaking out backstage
like then the guy who was supposed to
prepare our video packages like the
nominees are right right they kept
assuring me like oh yeah it's great it's
coming along he just disappeared so he
had no video presentation so I'm
freaking out like the day of the event
and banner was the host and he kind of
like grabbed me and corralled me like in
a corner somewhere and he was just like
you got to get it together because if if
you look like everything's fine people
are gonna think everything's fine if you
look like everything's [__] up people
are gonna be like what am I doing here
so I you know held it together he hosted
it with um and Trina as well David
Banner and Trina hosted um the first
show so I had asked Khalid to do the
opening set so Caleb brought I mean
everybody you know Rick Ross did
hustling
um actually Plies opened the show and
nobody in the industry knew who Plies
was but he was like the hottest thing in
the streets in Florida like they just
dropped plus from Fort Myers right he
was from Fort Myers yeah and I remember
like Pimp C asking me about him after
the show like yo
you know can I get his mixtape can I get
his number so we helped him out a lot
with that that was like a big look for
him wow
um supplies perform Rick Ross uh cool
and Dre came out Trick Daddy
um Pitbull T-Pain uh and then we had
like young jock Pimp C and Bun B for the
first time since pimpa got out Jeezy
came out on stage with them
um but honestly Wayne was supposed to be
the headliner like Wayne performed last
but it people thought it was over after
and they were like we can't talk yeah
top UGK uh ludicrous performed
um I think he was filming I think it's
on his MTV diary wow I'll just saying
that's like Peak gluta that's like we
had I mean I I got texts afterwards I I
think uh well bun was there but I think
I think little John didn't make the show
but he was texting me afterwards and
like bun was texting me like I can't
believe you or no bun bun got up and
accepted their award and he was like
honestly I didn't know if I was gonna
come to this thing based basically like
I thought it was gonna be just I'm glad
we came I mean it was it was Hood like
it wasn't it wasn't polished at all but
he was like you know this is this is for
the South like I'm glad we came and you
know people were texting me like you
know you like to to get a text from
Little John like wow I heard that what
you pulled off was amazing
like I can't can't really top that so
that was a crazy time in the how many um
award shows did you guys do three three
of them and then so kind of take me to
what ended I learned that I I hated
organizing events yeah Live Events are
are tough especially with so many very
it's different to do like a concert and
there's one guy performing but the
variables that are involved in pulling
together travel hotels that when you
know they do the BET Awards and they do
the source Awards they have production
companies that do this and you were the
production company I was a production
company and I would never put myself
through that oh I can imagine it was
some good times because you're talking
all the managers Miami I had Wayne on
this phone or management arguing with
the security didn't want to let him in
with his bags or whatever I had Jeezy
here with a hundred I need 100 tickets
because he's beefing with Pimp C it was
just
I
remember that wow Pimp C did not come to
the ozone Awards because of that
somebody wise talked him out of coming
because he was texting me like you're
gonna have blood on the floor and it was
I I did write about it in the book um
but I'm glad that that
uh right here I'm glad that that was
resolved with no no Bloodshed but yes I
was a 700 page book on Pimp C does touch
on these uh fun times at the ozone
Awards I was going to ask you um what
was because we always we know about the
legendary uh Source award drama and I
mean BT Award drama and was there ever
anything that popped off oh yeah
what was not to the not to the source
Awards level but um well that first year
when we had all the Miami artists or all
the Florida artists perform trick was
the final performance and I think there
was something I don't know something
with him and Ross or whatever but he's
so he ended his set like there's you
know I'm the uh there's only one mayor
in Miami and y'all are my proteges or
whatever he threw the mic down and so
that was they had like a little
something backstage or whatever Ross has
had some some something's backstage with
a few people yeah
so was that the worst that it ever got
where there was like a an altercation
because look when you have everyone
under the same roof and it's like you
said you're the production company so
this is not like MTV and there's like
like you're handling everything so like
well Houston was the craziest we had the
fire marshal trying to shut us down and
um the riot police like they had them
lined up outside who was attending at
the same time were you were most worried
about with Houston
well I wasn't I wouldn't say that I was
worried it was just a lot going on but
Trey and Trey punched Mike Jones I
didn't actually see it and um
Trader truth punch Mike Jones at this
ozone Awards and then Mike still came up
I mean to his credit Mike still came up
and did whatever presentation he was
supposed to do with the little Band-Aid
or whatever in his face so
I don't really know what that was
what they were that's a professional
imagine
but I brought
him for that you know um